you come from above
like him
he will burn the world to find you
who
the Conqueror
Kang the Conqueror is the new iconic
villain in the MCU
we knew we wanted to go to places that
we've never been and hitting Ant-Man
against a major villain felt perfect
audiences have seen a version of this
character in the series Loki
this is wild
in our film he's very different Kang is
an infinite number of different personas
and you need an actor to be able to pull
that off and that is Jonathan Majors I
can rewrite existence and shatter
timelines in this film this is really a
side of him we haven't seen this is his
baddest self I will take my revenge on
those who banished me and I will burn
them out of time
I think the film is awesome about how
time plays within our relationship
love friendship Legacy Ant-Man versus
tank this is it people gonna lose their
mind
you're out of your league Ant-Man
[Music]